the preliminary hearing in the hazing
death of a Penn State student resumes
this morning in Pennsylvania Timothy
Piazza died in February after a
fraternity event that involved heavy
drinking lawyers for 16 defendants want
the case thrown out they argue the
evidence does not warrant a trial and a
Warner is at the center County Criminal
Court in Bellefonte she spoke with an
attorney preparing to question a key
prosecution witness and a good morning
good morning well preliminary hearings
usually lasts just minutes but this one
is entering its fourth day it actually
began back in June there are 16
defendants appearing at this hearing
each one of them trying to show why he
is not responsible for Piazza's death in
Joey m's case charges should have never
been filed attorney William Brennan
represents Joseph M Jr who is facing one
count of reckless endangerment a
misdemeanor
prosecutors say aims can be seen on
surveillance video striking Timothy
Piazza hard in the abdomen while he was
drunk and incapacitated but Brennan says
Joey M's makes what I would call a cameo
appearance and we presume that he may
have tapped him on the torso like hey
bud wake up
that's not criminal Piazza would later
died of a ruptured spleen among other
injuries according to a pathologist your
client is on video how damaging is that
for him and your case I believe it
exculpate or tends to show the lack of
criminality on Joey's part 18 members of
the now shuttered Beta Theta Pi
fraternity have been charged of the 10
with misdemeanors - waived their right
to the preliminary hearing eight others
were charged with involuntary
manslaughter and aggravated assault the
most severe charges Tom Klein is the
Piazza family's attorney some were
responsible for the planning some were
responsible for the execution and some
were responsible for the cover-up and
some were responsible for one two and
three Piazza a sophomore was gravely
injured during what prosecutors allege
was a night of drunken hazing the 19
year olds blood alcohol content was
estimated at roughly four times the
legal limit he fell down a flight of
stairs and hit his head
repeatedly often in view of his
fraternity brothers no one called for
help until the following morning he was
unconscious this hearing is supposed to
last until Friday to give all those
remaining defense attorneys a chance to
cross-examine the lead investigator but
if prosecutors decide to requestion that
witness or defense attorneys file new
motions it could be a while before we
find out when and if this will all move
to trial glad thanks Anna